[Musique]
hmm
um
[Musique]
tellement [
Musique]
continuez comme ça
[Musique]
on dirait que nous sommes sur le point d'atteindre la
position de pré-lancement requise à
quelques degrés du
Falcon 9 et de la capsule Dragon
deux un
et zéro se lève  même la gravité ne contient pas l'
humanité lorsque nous explorons
comme un pour tous le
dragon d'équipage pourra utiliser sa
caméra infrarouge pour repérer le
contact
dragon spacex capture douce confirmée
[Musique]
les démocrates veulent vous enlever vos
armes ils veulent vous enlever vos soins de santé
ils  ils veulent vous enlever votre vote ils
veulent vous enlever votre liberté ils veulent vous
enlever vos juges
ils veulent tout vous enlever